bismillah hamdulillah Salaam alaikum
greetings of peace thank you for tuning
in to the Deen show and this month and a
Ramadan we're gonna be bringing you some
exciting new episodes on the Deen show
and we got a special treat you know
beyond all the media hype and the
sensationalism people turning on all the
different news reports and you usually
have a lot of negativity associated with
the truth
you know Jesus when he came he preached
the truth didn't he but people spit at
him they mocked him they ridiculed him
was he bringing falsehood or he was
bringing truth he was bringing Islam he
was calling people to the truth and they
drove him out and many people now one of
my guests who are coming out today
he saw beyond the hype and he's here on
the D show to tell us his story on why
when you got all this negativity
associated with Islam why'd he accept it
he's a african-american Puerto Rican
here on the Deen show to tell us his
story very amazing story you don't want
to go anywhere we'll be right back with
Kenan here on the D show
this is the this is the Kenan on the D
show it's a beer
how you been my brother really good I
open the show I mean it seems like you
don't watch too much TV do you I mean
back when you accepted Islam
you know today and yesterday always you
know whenever there has been the truth
coming along there's always opposition
to it but it seems like you got past all
the sensationalism all the media hype
and you accepted Islam yeah that's true
that's true
growing up all you surrounded all I was
surrounded by was negativity but when
you're surrounded by that your whole
life it seems normal to you you don't
realize what you should be doing and
what you should not be doing so it was
really tough really tough distinguishing
the two you know doing good as opposed
to doing bad so growing up most I spent
most of my life in Logan Square Chicago
no Chicago disappoints you can want to
raise here in Chicago yeah
parents separated when I was about 3 or
4 years old I don't really remember but
I just remember moving back and forth to
my mother to my father so it was really
tough seeing my parents separate spent
most of my life with my mother I say
about half of my life was with my mother
but I still maintain that relationship
with my father so I wasn't up until high
school when things started progressing
for the worst as far as living that life
of
you know drinking smoking girlfriends
you name it
up until I was about 18 or 19 very good
friend of mine who I grew up with was a
Muslim and I didn't know anything about
Islam at all I've been to churches all I
knew was that Jesus peace be upon him
came down died for our sins very general
dead that's what you did you just what
you believe there's a Christian but you
were taught that's what I was taught but
at the same time I was a little confused
on who I should pray to how to pray and
what was the right way of doing it but I
always prayed that's one thing I did
even though I did it
sacredly on my own in my room I always
prayed asking for forgiveness protection
and I didn't really tell anything tell
anybody about it now who are you praying
to were you praying because the
Christian belief is that there's a
three-in-one so Jesus is God the Father
is God the Holy Ghost is God and you
said you're confused about this so which
who are you praying to it was Jesus at
times and God at times yeah I wasn't
sure mm-hmm I was not sure at all even
though I did go to church I wasn't
really taught about Christianity so I
didn't really know too much I just know
that there was a higher power out there
that guided us and gave us the things
that we have in our life today yes so at
the age of 18 I found I was gonna be a
father right then and there I know I had
to change big responsibility not very
big being you know still out there
partying you know it's it's it's is that
like a wake up call
definitely so at this point were you
religious at that time or you were still
like clubbin hanging out just I was
still hanging out yeah working a lot you
know very busy
so at the age of eighteen very close
friend of mine I mean even though I
known him since grammar school I wasn't
really taught about Islam or the way of
life I just knew that you had to pray
five times a day don't eat pork stuff
like that I wasn't really taught about
it so just one day we were hanging out
and he started I was telling him how I
felt as far as praying and just the way
we should be living our lives and how we
should treat people and I always had a
good heart
he's seen that he knew that so he just
he just ran it by me you should learn
about Islam I was like well I don't know
anything though tell me tell me what I
should do what would you know so he's
just telling me all you know it's just
very easy you know but the main thing
that started is like I was telling them
how how the media you know brings out
you know this life that we live now
there's a way is the way that we should
be living our life forever as far as
drinking partying cars I mean like all
the bad things that glorified right
exactly
so he's like that's because people are
living for this life here's a life after
this if God takes your life today you
will be standing in front of him so if
you're doing all this her arm how what
do you think is gonna happen so the
Muslims telling you this yes yeah he's
telling this in the whole time I didn't
know what to say I was just listening
and I was so amazed by it it's like it
hit me right away I was like wow you
know and everything made sense
everything he was saying made sense he
start explaining like the fundamental
beliefs of Islam and everything
everything just made sense to me as
opposed to before you said things
weren't making sense I was confused but
it was just so simple you know of what I
was learning right then and there so
that night I went home and I was just
thinking about a lot of things
everything my whole life and what I've
been doing this whole time so but it
didn't I started thinking about my
family like they don't they don't know
about Islam and what if this what is
that you know I'm only 18 19 years old
I'm you know I started getting a little
frightened so a few months later it was
a New Year's Eve I was still going to
Juma and I was I was so wait now you
you've accepted at this point I don't
accept it at this time you didn't accept
us but you're going to Juma I'm going to
Juma
he's taking you along with them you're
making me he's teaching me how to pray
mm-hmm I'm loving it I'm I'm feeling
happier but you didn't accept Islam yet
I accept Islam yet so New Year's Eve
it's going to Friday prayer and a friend
of mine was like you know are you ready
are you ready I'm like ready I don't
know I really know anything you know I I
think it's a little too fast just making
up excuses so you're making excuses up
yeah and they're asking you are you
ready are you ready hold it right there
we got to go to break so they're asking
you to giving you an invitation you're
gonna accept Islam you're like making
all these excuses up a lot more to this
story when we come back with Kenan here
on the Deen show
imagine understanding the Koran in its
original Arabic and feeling closer to
Allah it's something we all want but
you've never had time it doesn't have to
be so daunting half of the Quranic words
are just 125 words that occur 40,000
times in different grammatical forms and
understand Quran Academy can help you
learn these words and more in only 9
hours
sign up today at WWN Quran calm
back here on the D show with Kenan
boricua
I mean poor Rican yes all right all
right now so people are excited because
they're like okay the anticipation is
building up you're loving the message of
Islam simplicity it makes sense you're
going to the gym are the Friday prayers
and they're like okay are you ready and
you're making excuses what happens next
I said okay let's let's do it I'm ready
no wait not so now finally you finally
right then and there I was like okay
this I'm ready let's do it after how
many excuses why were you in why do you
think you were making up excuses now we
see a lot of this a lot of times people
know Islam is the truth but sometimes
they're not courageous enough they hear
all the negative stereotypes associated
with Islam what my family my friends I
might not be the cool kid on the block
anymore right so you were going to build
up this courage so you finally did but
how come before you didn't have the Kurt
what was it that you why were you making
up all these excuses I don't know I
think it was because I was just
surrounded by I just everything came so
fast yeah you know I was looking at my
past a lot yeah and I was just I was
just a little scared now and so
apprehensive yes yeah and so I decided
to do it and right when I started
reciting when I was making Shahada I
started crying tears started falling
down my face when you when you enter
this like there's that proclamation that
you make and then you did the Shahada
and you start crying started crying I
didn't know why that happens to a lot of
people a lot of people when they accept
Islam they they end up you just feel
like a weights been lifted on yeah
absolutely and I was crying the whole
time and then all these people were
coming forward people I don't even know
people that don't even know me and
they're recording me they're taking
pictures but I didn't care about any of
that I was just
thinking I just I was just like no words
can explain it and were you happy very
happy very happy
after that I started meeting all these
people and those that five ten minutes I
have got the most love and in the
embrace then I had what I had my whole
life growing up from all the the
welcoming hugs and welcoming hugs and
then just smile your new family embrace
my whole family from your whole you felt
more loved that day when you accepted as
longing in your whole life
yes yes I had a loving family but it was
just it was amazing and from this day
forward every time I hear somebody
accepting Islam and saying the Shahada I
just I want to cry every time so but
after that like you said I felt as if a
bunch of weight was taken off me I felt
lighter happier and I knew that no
matter what I did before was was was
gone yeah and I had to start fresh and
really think hard about the decisions I
make from now forward so I knew I had to
start with watching who I hang out with
because you know the Shaitaan comes to
you from your friends and sometimes
family so I knew that if I really wanted
to change I had to really think hard
about the decisions I make so because
sometimes you have you know the the
friends that you've developed all these
bad habits with the drinking buddies the
clubbing buddies and they'll you know
make up every excuse to get you back
into the club you say I got no money W
I'll pay for you pay for your way I'll
pay the door thank
drinks I'll buy you all the drink just
to get you back right so you got to
start like excommunicating some of the
old drinking buddies clubbing buddies
because you don't wanna fall back into
that that bad trap right exactly and
even if they said that we're not gonna
do any of that I know that's that's all
we did
yeah so misery loves company right yeah
exactly so I was just tell them no I
died
I'm fine I'm did you try to like a lot
of people you know when they realize
that this is the truth now they
naturally because you care about people
you want to share did were any of them
hearing it or most people like no I felt
like they took it as a phase I was going
through yeah like you know this guy this
you know nobody expected any change from
me I can tell I wasn't wild I wasn't you
know I was just so deep into it that
they felt as if they can never quit
those things so they took it the same
way for me
you know like this guy he's one of us
he's not gonna yeah
he's not gonna change we'll see it's the
more the yo the Yolo lifestyle you only
live once
exactly yeah yeah but it's but the Islam
is telling us no no youyou actually
continue living exactly right you are
gonna be accountable and that is what
really triggered you to think when the
Muslim was talking about the reality of
people just living for this life but
there's another life let's talk about
that now now you know Islam connects you
to the eternal home paradise
accountability in this life and now
you're really conscious of your creator
and your actions you want to do good you
want to live a good wholesome life talk
to us about this I knew that I started
educating myself first of all in order
to share you have to obviously know what
you're talking about
in since it was still new to me I will
still fall weak to a lot of things but I
was more conscious of my actions I can
honestly say that my fear of God grew my
Creator I was just so right then in
their fear you fear the consequences so
I realized that if I want the best for
me I have to make smarter decisions so
it was a battle I knew I was going to be
tested and from there on I just I died
slowly but surely started changing and
have your parents have your family
members seen the positive change in your
life your character getting better
your human being developing being more
responsible being reductive a productive
citizen productive member of society
absolutely that's that's the main thing
I can't be a hypocrite that's the one
thing that I knew that I had to do was
not be a hypocrite yeah cuz you know
hypocrisy puts you in the lowest depths
of Hell fire so I didn't want to be a
hypocrite to show them that that I'm I'm
not who I thought I was and living that
life is not going to be the right thing
so they accepted they accepted my
decision right away they seemed to
change in me but then again it was still
new to them because we weren't raised or
around anything like that at all yeah so
just all about trying it's all about
trying to do good and if you tried and
things only get better from there they
get better they get better definitely
now you got a road map that you live by
while the people are hipping and hopping
into the club and still not happy you
left the club and you're happy and so
much more to talk about right back to
talk to Keenan and get the rest of his
story here in the Dean show don't go
anywhere we'll be right back
to save one life as though you had saved
all of humanity
show kindness to your parents just as
they cherished you in John
giving charity of the good thing you
were even a smile is charity explore the
real values of his land
have you ever wondered what Islam and
Muslims are truly about what do Muslims
believe who was Muhammad do Muslims
believe that Jesus will return is Islam
respectful of other beliefs what does
the Quran say about women would you like
to learn the truth about Islam would you
like to read the Quran for yourself find
the answers for yourself call toll-free
877 why Islamic back here on the Deen
show with Kenan getting his story and
interesting story also inside of your
story is that you also have an older
brother who you really didn't get along
with right now
Riley in your family between you and
your brother but come to know that your
brother also accepted Islam is this
right very interesting tell us about
this how this came about
and a few months before I converted I
see a but for about three or four years
my brother and I didn't talk we had our
own issues and we just didn't get along
living to different lifestyles so we
barely talked until one night I'm
pulling up to my house and I get a call
from my brother
and he goes are you are you Muslim and
I'm like like no but I'm you know I'm
still learning and I will be Muslim soon
he goes man on I just converted a month
ago really I was shocked out I was
speechless
you know speechless because I mean we
didn't even talk that little only we
seen the light at the same time so he's
like yeah mom was telling me that you
don't eat pork anymore so I was like you
know you know Puerto Ricans they love
pork yeah so we we ate a lot of work
going out but you know I want to go that
you mentioned the pork I want to go to
this clip because some Christians or
anonymous not yet Muslims they'll hear
like pork what's the big deal pork but
we're gonna go to this clip by actually
a Christian pastor who's telling his
congregation to stay away from pork real
interesting we'll go ahead and listen to
this then let's talk a moment about pork
ham bacon pepperoni
these are some of the things that the
scripture tells us we should not eat
this has to do with anything that comes
from a pig a hog a swine and I know some
of you love pork chops you love ham and
cheese sandwiches I grew up on all that
I love bacon but for our health sake we
have to be willing to make some changes
God knows what's best for us
and back in the Bible days the pig was
considered unclean
it was never considered a source of food
and one of the main reasons why was the
pig will eat anything a pig it's waste
and garbage this is kind of gross but a
pig were in its own dead child a pig
will eat other sick and infected animals
they're scavengers and what's
interesting is the pig has one of the
quickest and poorest digestive systems
of any animal it takes only four hours
and that's not good the cause the
digestive system is so quick and so poor
many times the toxins from the food are
not properly eliminated and they are
stored in the pigs fat that means that
pig can eat all kinds of Filth and
garbage it can eat other infection for
hours later it's sent to the slaughter
in butchered and a few days it's on your
plate at home you're having ribs the
problem is the toxins were never
properly eliminated from the pig that's
very interesting you see jo-jo Olsteen
is telling his congregation how many
tens of thousands stay away from port so
if you're Christian hey you should be
following also Jesus never ate pork or
none of the profits they also only
worship God and worship a Trinity or any
of these things and that's what you're
doing now so continue on you know your
brother says that he heard you didn't
eat pork and then what happened he's
like yeah I heard you didn't eat pork I
was like ah quit you know put all that
he's like wow he's like we're speechless
we didn't know what to say but he told
me he's like look man it's it's the
right thing to do it's the right way of
life this is how we should be living and
wow you're getting confirmation now from
your brother who you've been apart from
for several years and I love
and I had no clue because we were still
doing things we shouldn't have done he
was out doing his own I didn't know what
he was doing but what everybody's doing
right people just chasing parrot chasing
trying to make a paradise on earth right
chase in Virginia the material world's
just satisfying your desires that's it
right right so right then and there we
became we are not close now than we've
ever been so now you and your brother
are tight yeah we talk closer than ever
closer than ever Allah God it's great
look at that amazing hum do this so we
he wouldn't he knew more about Islam
than I did so he would tell me things
and I met the brother that taught him
about Islam and it's a really good guy
and we're close now so that's so you
know it was really it was it was a major
I knew I had support and I knew I had
somebody by my side because before then
I knew that okay if I distance myself
from my friends and my family so I can
do better then I felt like I was going
to be maybe alone yeah but but you're
you're not alone so tell us more we're
almost out of time
you know Ramadan we're here in Ramadan
and you've gotten to experience it all
so you know we know Islam is based on
five pillars the one is that what you
did jihad that accepting Islam is to to
agree with what with what's in your very
nature that there's nothing worthy of
worship except the Creator your maker
the one you're going to return back to
I'm only only gonna worship Him the same
God that Jesus worship and Mohammed is
the brother of Jesus moulds of Abraham
is the final messenger you accept all of
them as messengers not gods or any part
of God or divinity we've got no just
worshiping one God and now praying five
times a day you establish the prayer
five times a day is to pray it was that
challenging yes it's a time it's but you
finally did it
I finally did it come didn't I my first
Ramadan was very difficult
didn't only fast it may be a few times
yeah up until the the third the third my
third Oh Madonn I fasted every month and
every day that went by me fasting you
guys trying to get a hang of it fine he
got into the spirit of I felt so much
better
yeah better and I was happier and this
is something I can share with people
because I knew me as a Muslim I had this
is something I have to do and I just
felt excited that I can be able to tell
other people that I have accomplished
that because some people are like oh you
can't eat that's you know it's crazy but
I explained to them why and and it's
just something I can share and be very
proud of and would help me from from
there on there's nothing that we do in
Islam that goes against humanity as a
whole that that is harmful for you had
no negative side effects everything we
do produces good results not that
everything we were doing back in Jogja
leah the days of ignorance that the
everything that we were doing mostly all
of it produces bad resolve the drinking
with the drugs with whatever was doing
that and and left that you you usually
don't want you don't want to go back to
that right you're scared yeah and if
you're lost upon without and you you're
you're scared you don't want to do that
you don't want to you don't want to face
the consequences that's all it is and
people don't want to make these changes
because they want to be free and they
don't want to have rule live by any
rules or anything like that so it's it's
still something that uh you have to
practice and realize that there's
nothing but benefits from when you
worship and you live for your Creator
there's nothing but benefits from there
on so you're living the purpose of life
now I am you're happy now I'm happy what
advice do you have for those people out
there who are still happening hipping to
the clubs or you know what it's all
about the party it's all about just
showing off and the bling-bling or
whatever lifestyle they're following and
they just not happy and now they're
tuning in to the DS show and they liking
what you have to say what do you what
advice do you have for first surround
yourself by positive people
if you have any questions reach out find
those answers don't feel afraid you want
to know what about Islam talk to a
Muslim start praying if you don't know
how try to find out how it's all about
trying to do good so it's not about
putting that effort in and living for
God not living for today beautiful thank
you so much for being with us thank you
for God willing people can benefit from
your story and we wish you all the best
this Ramadan and hopefully inshallah log
'yes the way to Jenna so we can be in
general and paradise together by living
a good guy conscious life and trying to
develop ourselves to be the best human
beings possible in Charlotte God thank
you thank you very much and that was
Kenan here on the Deen show enjoyed this
Ramadan get the most out of this Ramadan
learn about Ramadan if you are not yet
Muslim learn about Islam you see you
know Kenan look behind all that hype and
you see he was living for just the
material world that you only live once
mentality to the $0.55 mentality and the
jay-z mentality but you know what I
don't get you anywhere you know a lot of
pain comes with living that lifestyle
and not of painkillers but when you live
Islam the way of life of all the
messages of God you have that peace that
tranquility you live with that love for
your Creator and you live satisfying not
just the flesh but you satisfy the soul
and until you give you a heart back to
the one who created the heart you'll
never be happy you'll never truly have
peace contentment and satisfaction in
life so when you see one of the amazing
proofs is about Islam and you have a
whole world up against it and it's still
continuing to blossom
no one can suppress it because it is
indeed the truth from the one who
created you with a simple believable
message and all the proof to back it up
there's only one creator and your maker
who made you that's the one who you're
gonna have to return back to and then
it's either the Hellfire paradise you're
going to be accountable for what you did
in this life and all the Creator is
asking us to do is to appreciate the
Plus blessings the countif o blessing
that he's given you be thankful and
grateful and start by asking him for
guidance and if you're sincere he will
definitely facilitate a way or you can
just go ahead and do the alternative
keep following your lusts and desires
and see what happens when you die
because death is approaching very very
soon we'll be in the grave and then what
you had ignored all the signs and even
this Dean show it just came to you you
were tuning in so be wise enough be
bright enough to really look into this
Dean this way of life that brings peace
prosperity and peace contentment like no
other call us at